hello and welcome to this video playing
LM kena Cass Tori square high rating
Chessmaster okay we have rated about
even if the ratings are not that high
yeah playing the Reggie system always I
think this had some weird static value
is acidic this formation
okay so black usually goes b6 or c5 okay
this is certainly not a bad move
yeah I wonder if I take here on to quite
remember I think you take
hmm so really contemplating night takes
it looks slightly off you had to take
with the night but in this particular
position I probably that's nothing to do
against it
nothing special
now they can probably take with an item
pawn takes is the most normal choice
okay so normally going for here
and through each one if I remember
correctly preparing me for I think C v
e4 Knight f6 Knight c3 is a position
that I had analyzed for my English
opening series I'm fairly certain if it
wasn't that it was a very similar system
so I'm thinking force write me a line of
six books by far like the logical move
Knight f6 Knight c3 c4 94 95 is not good
because of each five and ninety five a
click we need tools you can sacrifice
the piece on d4
I mean it's not a sacrifice you know but
I can allow him to take it that's
probably the better phrase this even was
played recently relatively recently I
think in the US Championships between
ticket was so it only shook 95 Queen e2
I defy scoonie to 2495 em that wins
material back with interest
while you get to get to Bishop parity
who which is some kind of material
advantage the main idea of Queen e2 is
just to an open up the D file Form D one
the interesting thing is if he goes
Bishop c5 there must some extremely
strange line I think there's a line a
group give one Bishop takes Knight b5
Bishop f2 Queen f2 there's something
like that whereas the White gets
fantastic compensation for the pawn but
I don't quite remember analyze this
analyze this and had it in my repertoire
so this is a motivator when you're not
on camera I can actually look it up
presenting in your chess plays files or
some I really never do that it's a form
of cheating of course but sometimes it
would be helpful sometimes don't
remember my own opening idea and also
maybe
you think about this whole moment Bishop
c5 I don't remember what what only
should play together he had a bad
position on the opening he played
something non critical I think but I'm
not entirely sure now Bishop c5 must be
the critical move Bishop c5 t1 t2 tick
should have to queen of to the knight is
hanging
now he goes for it this is the moment
where you if she know stuff yeah you're
probably just going to blow blowing out
of the water because there was an
extremely dangerous position for black
end-credit certain look Edie one is
correct moving moving the 90s 94 ex
extremely lame so with Iggy one Bishop T
for light piece 5 Bishop F to Queen
after blacks queen is attacked and f96
also remember something wacky with g4g
for the kingdom and a slime now
sometimes you just remember like
fractions also I can get both rooks can
be can be put on d1 I wonder what is the
best
so I feel greedy one but okay if I go
look 81 81 that's the better move if you
just declines everything and like the 27
or so what is of course just better
after 94 I'm going to do this now oh you
see that
I'm really curious what exactly hide
analyze I can look it up in my email
files but I remember that Bishop deform
there was some line where you can allow
to take and it was it was very very good
for work my list was a super strong
compensation so he doesn't go for this
okay yeah here Knight e4 is what I
mentioned just better for white
I just came the bishop crown but it is
solid of course here he's got a solid
position anything else
one just go for the bishops I wait
actually night in for no that's not a
problem
Bishop a three-year but I can just take
that play Knight d5 and then Knight to
g6
yes so I will probably win the bishop
town
now that line was taking us to critical
one
yeah what is he going to do it it's not
easy to defend this position maybe like
eight five and four bishop a six in some
cases I might have also discovered
discovered a text by the night if the
knight on e5 is currently unprotected so
a knight move is a discovered attack
yeah I thought I thought that wouldn't
work one thing that I was unsure about
is taking ninety-five bishop eighty-six
very strange-looking variation but maybe
maybe this is his idea
Bishop a six go for the pin Knight takes
c6 should be tool doesn't work
no it doesn't work okay and and if I
take and go f4 that's it's the most
aggressive move or a for immediately
and like I would like to really put the
Queen on a three-night b5 let's let's
check this again is got Bishop a six
mm very loose somehow night see tool
that doesn't let anything he just goes
back
and that's pushing back one important
thing is that this SEM drives this night
away from any influence on f3 so if he
moves the night back this night b5 is
getting more interesting as Bishop a
six-night a3 Bishop e2 roopd tool looks
good staff like five next or so I'd
adjustment must be better for one even
though the two lights look a bit wacky
for a three and a four
but sometimes which is what it is
you have to play the hand you're down
and 96-95 Queen moves Knight d6 should
be great
ninety-seven looks lame I don't see a
tactic really 96 there's a really bad
square
man looks that looks really good unless
I'm missing stuff
don't see a bit more fine
at least nothing that really looks like
okay that's equal yeah or something even
better
every line looks good for me
[Music]
in essence blacks problem is that it's
got some dogs dark square weaknesses now
and I'm just better developed now look
on the one everything is a little bit
quicker and it's got that unprotected
bishop might be five is a temple and so
on they're a couple of things coming I'm
sort of coming together here that's
probably been English some yeah some
things add up that same that's probably
a bit more sophisticated way of putting
it
no I don't see a good more night welcome
to the six maybe
maybe ninety seven trying to make that
work
now maybe it's not particularly fun 1975
I think doesn't net much 95 wait till he
goes to g6 this is something that I
basically had um yeah more or less
ignored for general reasons as the night
is not well placed
let's room the night is not well placed
but so of course you can go down yeah
night b5 licks looks like the normal
move put it on d6 in 595 doesn't feel
correct my problem piece is the night on
a forum this is really not good so
Knight to d6 and threatening maybe not
that much
maybe not that much okay I also have
rook c8 rook c1 threatening look c7 it's
not so easy to play looks the ADA for
black I can actually take take a 7 just
just grab stuff it looks really good
back to it
and after like a a 696 is just fantastic
am i maybe Bishop a6 now that's a move I
didn't really consider
pretty that's a pretty awful pin and
maybe it's probably not the end of the
world but still a bit bit of an awful
thing that's something that's something
I missed
and I cannot play because he certainly
just takes it I can play this night back
covering b5 but and that is not really
working with other drugs e1 perhaps
stupids folder amp in nad
and maybe I just just ignore that and
play like E 5 95 Bishop takes pawn takes
Knight to c3 25 just like brutal brutal
chess
any five looks right anyway so let's do
it yeah I think 95 looks like the move
the other moves looks strange really
97 for when a playbook c7 anyway why I
can take the book on it of course a yes
sequel 95 or does he have some kind of
counter play counter attack yet this one
I thought about it but I thought that
this is just good and where's the night
going now when I wrong I mean they're
still hate is hanging and the the the
the night the same so what's the deal 95
now it looks like with some good moves
widest I'm going to win the tower should
be 5
you noticed it so that's been one of the
more annoying things
well should cheeks porn chicks
I just need to get rid of them let's
make it to get rid of the Queen and
things fall apart
don't see it I don't see a winner
95 85 and I'm really brilliant some
issues they I have with this pin it
really feels like with a good move and
winning we should be 585 a 3 not even
check is quit this good job but is it
the best quickly 4 is good ham there are
many moves that are just good but
determine what the best one is it's not
so easy for me
that night on g6 doesn't have many
squares you know if I get in this Bishop
takes pawn takes 95 o KF v e5 is
actually hanging so I'm assessing you
may have some ideas on that night
do I miss candidate more screechy voice
also move that I considered but
religious amok see a door so a4 is not
good yeah I have I'm missing something
here something Elementary
you
I'm certainly missing something
and 24 doesn't really add up my gut
feeling is that Bishop d5 is correct and
I'm not I'm not seeing how it how it
actually wins
I can play Bishop takes politics f5
playing on that night maybe d4 land is
an idea
[Music]
Queen c4 is also interesting
take takes Knight takes rook cakes and
it's also good for white but I don't
quite see a pillar and I feel like this
one are we going to make a blitz game
out of this now this is something where
the engine at the end will find
something I'm completely certain I
cannot play move now and it was a really
terrible calculation job in the position
where there should be something and
found nothing going back and forth
between moves so we make a little bit
more than a blitz game out of this now
I'm threatening to take so if you may
move the rook I'll take before take a
seven so I'm winning a pawn in this kind
of situation and in general I'm playing
with all pieces well here is his g6 is
not not out I mean I saw pretty early on
that this move is pretty good but I felt
like I should have a killer I didn't
find the killer
okay let's see what killer Kass is doing
now maybe just moving the Queen he's not
moving at all
okay I cannot move the Queen okay so it
says something else yeah wait wait wait
were like 95 is the movie also 95 but it
is to take you and take a seven mallet
just win the pole doing the pawn and the
position should be good so I looked lamb
the book to d6 okay so in the Knight to
d6 is something that would be good
a key em take me and III 93
not entirely certain what the best way
is here technically maybe cake actually
and then a 393 rupee one as a self pin
and it's a self pin
95 or 96 we have to watch out for my
time as well
I don't know if I wanted to trade the
problem battle ok so here just taking
yeah taking us good mighty symbol can go
evil before yeah the b-pawn is extremely
weak and try to get damaged I don't
quite see thank you and bring all the
king of the first is Bishop is not
really that great okay so now I came
back to go back to b5 my like
like two completely decentralized yeah
this is also a good square here so much
check threatening checkmate not a nice
situation okay he kind of lost composure
them it was not yet made glue to take
the pawn this is a good thing to have a
little bit of an increment you know that
this is going to end an illogical way
the worst that can happen here is the
checkmate with night and night and
Bishop but with an increment time
control this is really very easy to do
and he resigned yeah it was a that was a
tough game and I'm really curious about
them and about this critical situation
where took an extremely long time and
fairly suits and I didn't play the best
move I don't know I don't know it was
really difficult so um the first
critical situation is here
when I played Queen e2 and again that
was something that I knew from my work
on the English opening repertoire this
is a good position care of something
like this right is in a really good
shape getting the material back
something something like I can take a 70
taking five or take your five take you
seven it both looks good that is not the
critical move Bishop c5 the samel
critical rookie d1 I remember that
correctly yeah and now you played Queen
e7 which is most solid and seems best
but this this is a chunky line here and
then takes yeah this is what I
remembered from my repertoire this and
this and then there was something really
funny with g4 like the engine is finding
it I guess like here and then Queen a
for our g4 yeah a nike 74 that was that
was the move then I remembered during
the game something crazier it looks
crazy
but he's very strong you have to take 23
all of a sudden there's fantastic attack
coming yeah I remember that g4 was what
sauce was in them so that would have
been extremely critical
the acquiesce 7 seems better though and
I played nine a4 as the engine suggests
and this this seems to by riot and up
and I'm better
so we five-year is stronger and then f5
ok 95 wasn't really good or Bascom so
this was already very strong it looks
very strong it's good why exactly
because I have I can do this I can do
this which is a double attack so that
was stronger yeah that just wasn't that
good kind of occurred to me quickly
because that Bishop a6 resource he went
Queen easy several but yeah Bishop well
here okay here I was reasonably happy
yeah because this must be good would be
fine and the engine agrees I just have
the more active pieces and this is not
looking all that great that's this now
we had just take the pawn that's what
the engine wants to do or take and do
this that also looks quite logical but
he went to e7 and now look c1 wasn't
good I should play e5 okay 58 is okay
again so that was a not so well played
part of the game reliever and okay II
five okay five is the most obvious move
you know what I didn't really I didn't
really understand at the development how
dangerous or good f5s there's Jeremy
forces in high 2h8 I didn't understand
that look see one so look the a bishop a
six wasn't good book the aid was better
yeah I was thinking it here I just take
actually but this is a naive way to
think you should take this room okay
okay so we had this b5 here and now I
should just take a age I didn't really
think about that
hmm
it is sounds pretty simple I didn't
really realize that I can cover the
ocean and was a lot better mysterious
okay I went here I mean a that looks
good and it seems to win as well but and
okay Quincy for actually is one of the
better moves me yeah me I saw that this
is better for me but I have felt and
there must be something more and
decisive but the more decisive stuff was
before oh now I have to just take and I
use this opportunity and play this
position 96 was better okay now that's
not a realistic move I just take the
pawn to d6
which I think what I did cannot be bad
that forces them into the scalp in and
that's always going to be annoying 96 or
stronger okay why an ID takes d5 i
blundered upon you can do this I mean
that is that that ending is probably
very very good for white and should that
should win actually with good technical
play probably but I'm over looked at
okay by now we look let's sing of course
but so this happened now lost responding
yeah okay here there was some inaccurate
moves by both sides probably but I think
I didn't didn't to botch it up yeah so
I'm so reasonably happy I could have
taken on a aid that was a bit stronger
or not were there not a bit strong it
was a lot stronger but it didn't occur
to me at the time that I'm actually
covering the bishop
Queen that cringey to what we know 3
yeah it was a good game I think thanks
for watching